[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الخطر
2050 نهايه دجله والفرات
العراق لم يسمى عراقي سمي بلاد بايا بين
النهرين لوجود دجله والفرات 2050 نهر بردا
بسوريا جدول صغير
سيحول او ماذا سيحدث لدجله والفرات
سيكون جدولا صغير اذا لم نحافظ على دجله
والفرات
السبب الرئيسي هو قله المياه
واضافه الى اشياء اخرى فلت المطر التغيرات
المناخيه التي تحدث
في الكون
لندن هذا الصيف الصيف الماضي كل
المناطق اللي تحتوي على مناطق خضراء تحولت
الى مناطق غير خضراء بسبب قله المياه طبعا
حضاره ما بين حضاره الحضاره اللي كانت هنا
في حضاره عمرها 7000 سنه
اول من اوائل
الاشياء اللي حدثت في هذه الكره الارضيه
كانت هنا هذه واحده من عجائب الدنيا السبع
وهي جناء المعلقه لم نعرف لحد الان كيف
استطاعوا ان يصلوا بالماء من الارض الى
اربع متر هذا العقل العراقي
المشاكل العراقيون عملوا 7000 سنه وبعد
ذلك قبل 1200 سنه كان هنا شيء اول مركزين
بحثين بالعالمين بالعالم كانت في بغداد
هاوسو بيت الحكمه
وبعد هذا خلقنا الف براءه اختراع قبل 1200
سنه يستخدمها لحد الان
الخوارزميات وعلم الكمبيوتر هو من العراق
الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه هي من العراق
يكونون كيف الثوره الصناعي الرابعه من
العراق الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه
على الخوارزميات
حديد اعتمدت على الرياضيات اعتمدت على شيء
اسمه جبر هو من العراق السفر هو من العراق
ولكن ماذا سيحدث
ما هذا
احد يقدر يقول لي من الحاضرين ما هذا
الامن الامن الدول
يعتمد على المياه
ماذا سيحدث للمراه هنا هنا كان هناك مشكله
كبيره بين مصر واثيوبيا بسبب سد النهضه صح
ولا لا خلت المياه وزدت زياده المياه في
باكستان ماذا حدث كانت هناك فيضانات وفي
مناطق اخرى كان هناك جفاف فاختلفت
الموازين بسبب المشاكل التي تحدث
لانه احنا كانسان او كبشر بدينا نؤدي
للكره الارضيه بعد مرور حوالي 20 سنه
سنكون عشره مليار عشره مليار كيف هذه
الكره الارضيه سوف تغذي عشره مليار شخص
ماذا ساعفعل وماذا سيقدم التكنولوجي
والحصول او الحفاظ على الكره الارضيه
التكنولوجي والذكاء الاصطناعي عقل الانسان
هو اذكى كثيرا او اسرع كثيرا من عقله عقل
الاله الحقيقه الحقيقه الاله بدت
تغلب الانسان لماذا لان البشر عقل البشر
الذكي توصل على بناء اله ذكيه جدا تستطيع
ان تفوق على عقل الانسان
ولكن ما لماذا لان بدنا نستخدم
او الموجوده السابقه واستخدام عقول متعدده
لحل المشكله ليس فقط عقل واحد الاف من
العقول دخلناها في المشي نستخدمها فما هو
الذكاء الاصطناعي الذكاء الاصطناعي سوف
يدخل بكل بيت الذكاء الاصطناعي سوف يدخل
بكل جيب من جيوب البشر
وتنستخدمها من تقول له انطيني اللوكيشن
يستخدم جزء من الذكاء الاصطناعي ولازم يجب
ان نفرق بين الذكاء الاصطناعي
اكو اختلاف بيناتهم لا نخلط
طبعا ما في ما الفكره هناك مشاكل عديده
جدا
على نهر دجله والفرات وسيختفون
ماذا اقترح
ان نبدا باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي والتكنولوجي مع بعض
للحفاظ على دجله والفرات
بدايه هي عمل سدود او الستات او نواضم على
طول دجله والفرات وتحويل دجله والفرات الى
بحيرات
جاريه
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي نسيطر على هذه
الانظمه بحيث كل جزء من اجزاء دجله
والفرات يكون
محدد العلو مالته محدد وهذا ما نسميه
الانظمه الذكيه طبعا هذا جزء من الجزء
النظام الذكي او السدود الذكيه سوف تولد
الطاقه الكهربائيه النظيفه سوف لمعرفه
نقاءه نقاء الماء ماذا نفعل نحن في المدن
ناخذ ماء نظيف ونحل له الى ماء ونبعثه الى
الجنوب الفيديو اللي شفته بالقليل هو قبل
يوما اخذته باحد المجاري ان تسميها مجاري
المجاري للذب الماء الااسن في نهر دجله
العلماء العراقيين والعالمين يقول لك
لناخذ الماء المالح او ماء البحر
ولنحاول نحليه بس عندنا ماء نهر نهر ما
نقي لماذا نضع نعمل او نحول الماء الاسم
او الماء النقي الى ما اثم وبعدين نحاول
ان نحاول الماء المالح الى ماء نقي فهذه
وحده من الشغله اول اول عمليه اول عمليه
هو استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
وخصائص الذكاء الاصطناعي والتكنولوجي
للحفاظ على الماء لن نضع قطره ماء من دجله
والفرات في الخليج
امس كان هناك امطار كثيره ماذا فعلنا بهذا
الامطار
مباشره هذا لن يحدث ماذا تكلمت تكلمت قبل
قليل عن هذا هذا السد سيكون هناك
لاخذ الماء وتحويل هذه الماء الى بحيرات
مقفله في كل انحاء العراق وخاصه الباديه
العراقيه هناك باديه ويدونها ما عندنا
صحراء هناك باديه كيف نستطيع تحويل هذه
الباديه الى مزارع كبيره تغذي كل المدى
سوف تكون سله الغذاء من هنا من العراق
فيصير عندنا
مضخات كبيره تنقل الماء الى المناطق
الباديه العراقيه نعم طبعا هذه هذه القسم
من السجود وهذه الكنترول سيستم على هناك
شيء مهم هناك ثلاث مشاكل رئيسيه المشكله
ولا قله الماء وج
ود قله سوف
نحجز الذكيه الشغ
له
اللي ناخذه
ونحولها الى ماء ونرجعه في دجله والفرات
ماذا سنفعل
سنعيد تحويله ونعيد
نستخدمه في الاشياء الغير بشريه غسل
السيارات اضافه الى الزراعه ولا الصناعه
هاي اول مشكله المشكله الثانيه هي مشكله
الماء يذهب الى الخليج مباشره سوف نقف
وسوف نحاول المساعده على ايقاف هذا الشيء
وكل هذا سوف يصب في السيستين واللي تابعه
مساله اخرى هي
البحيرات الكبيره
لخزن الماء هذه البحيرات بها مشكله عظيمه
هي التبخر
احد طبعا قرات في مكان معين انه 50% من
ماء استفتاء يتبخر المشكله فقط يتبخر
والماء الباقي يكون مالح اكثر لانه من
يتبخر
واحده من الحلول طبعا واحده من الحلول
اللي انا اقدمها هي انه نبدا نعمل ما يسمى
فلوتنج
فكرتي حقيقه عن استعارات هاي الفكره بس
نحتاجها في العراق
عندهم بحيره ومغطيها كلها
هاي سولا بانس تولد لهم الطاقه الكهربائيه
لماذا وضعوها فوقه البحيرات لان لا يوجد
لديهم اماكن غير مزروعه تحتاجوا البحيرات
بنفس الفكره
الهنود ام لو اكبر فام اكبر مزرعه للسولار
بالعالم لماذا لا نفعل هذا نحن العراقيون
لماذا لا نرجع الى نقطه البدايه ونقول
لدينا اكبر
مكان نولد بها الطاقه الشمسيه النظيفه وهي
فوق بحيره الاثار والحبانيه والبحيرات
الاخرى
والاهم نقطه بهذه الشغله انه في توجد
لدينا مكان كبير في الامارات يولدون
الطاقه الكهربائيه ولكن الطاقه الكهربائيه
كل ثلاثه اسابيع الى اربعه لديهم مشكله
كبيره
وجودها فوق الماء النظافه تكون سهله
وجودها فوق الماء اكو نقطه اخرى وهي انه
التبريد سيكون سهل جدا لانه هذه الطاقه
الشمس او هذه اللوحات الشمسيه تحتاج الى
ان تبرد اذا ما تبردها تفقد خاصه خلال
سنتين وطبعا من اقول لك كيف راح نسوي هذا
تقول لي هل موجوده هي موجوده بس عندنا
الجامعات العراقيه سوف ينشط البحث العلمي
بالجامعات العراقيه سوف نبدا نصنع اكبر
مصانع
للالواح الشمسيه بالعالم السعوديه تعمل
على ان تسيطر على سوق صناعه البطاريات في
العالم لماذا لان كل السيارات بعد 2030
ستحول الى
سياره كهربائيه منها ستفكرون لماذا لا
نفكر بهذا الشيء
عندنا طاقه كهربائيه ولدنا طاقه نظيفه
حافظنا على ماء دجله والفرات والان نستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي بشيء اخر وهو الزراعه
الزراعه الذكيه اذا تقول اي شاب للشباب
هنا
خليني اعمل فلاح يرفض بس اذا اقول له ليش
ما نستخدم التكنولوجي في الزراعه يعني
ابسط شيء
نتكلم على اكبر قط
عه زراعيه
للحنطه والشعير بالعالم نتكلم هذا الشيء
فمن شو احتاج احتاج الى محراث كبير احتاج
الى
باللغه مالتنا تراكتور كبير هناك
بالحجم مال هذا
التراكتور يحتاج الى سائق تكنولوجي ما
تحتاج الى سائق ليش من السائق يكون خريج
الجامعه التكنولوجيه خريج جامعه بغداد
والكنتروليت
تكنولوجي موجوده بس اطورها اكثر هاي وحده
الشغله الثانيه السفره يكون كلها سقي ذكي
الشغله الثالثه
نفكر انه الناس متقدمين اكثر من عندنا اذا
تروح لاسبانيا العرب نحن العرب صدرنا الى
اسبانيا زراعه الزيتون اكبر مصدر للزيتون
بالعالم هو منو الاسبان لماذا استخدموا
العقل العربي
كيف استخدم العقل العربي اذا تروح على قصر
الحمراء تلاحظ انه علموا الاسبان كيف
يخزنون الماء
عندهم اماكن يجمعون الماء ويخزنوها وهذا
المؤمن يخزنوا يستخدموا
شهر واحد نفس الفكره وزعه على كل انحاء
المنطقه الكبيره الموجوده في اسبانيا
احواض وهذه الاحواض احواض سواها من التراب
وبعدين سوى بلاستيك سواء احواض وغطوها
يغطوها بطريقه بحيث ما تتاذى يعني
وبداوا يستخدمون التقطير الحديث هذا فكرتي
انه تتذكرون قلتلكم وتر بوم مضخات كبيره
هاي المضخات الكبيره ستربطه بالشبكات توزع
الى الباديه العراقيه فكل بالبادي العراقي
هاي الاحواض سوف تملا دائما عن طريق انظمه
ذكيه النقطه الاخرى هي هذه الانظمه الذكيه
ترتبط بالثلاثه اشياء اذا مطرت مثل اليوم
مثل امبارح
الشغله الثانيه هذا الشغله الثالثه هي
عندنا
الايام احتاج
اذا كان عندنا
نستخدم هذا الماء فدائما هذه الاحواض
حتكون ممليه الشغله اللي لازم يعرفوها
العراقي انه احنا من ناخذ الفرات ونضعه في
الخليج
بسبب مهم جدا لانه المياه الخليج المالحه
تاتي فنحتاج دائما نصفها في ماء من الماء
حلو علشان نحافظ على هاي طبعا التكنولوجي
نقدر نسوي بسهوله ناظم هذا الناظم ناظم
ذكي يعمل مع المد والجزر المد والجزر
اضافه الى الفيضانات اهم شيء بالماء هو
التنبؤ بما سيحدث نستطيع التنبؤ يعني
مبارح كان اكو مطر هذه سجود ذكيه راح تعرف
اكو مطر تعرف احنا عندنا بيتا موجوده اهم
شغله بالحياه هي وجود التنبؤ للمستقبل
التنبؤ المستقبل الذكاء الاصطناعي نستطيع
ان نتنبا ماذا سيحدث في السنه الجايه راح
يصير عندنا تن بؤ للمستقبل اذا يكون عندنا
مطر قليل فهاي الساحات المساحات الكبيره
اقل للزراعتها انا لان اعرف شو راح يصير
السنه الجايه اذا اذا هذا لا راح ازيدها
وهذا سوف يخلق زراعه صناعيه جديده يحول
العراق الى
مسافه الامم كل واضافه كل الامم بنيت على
المياه فما نحتاجه هو الاختراعات الجديده
اللي راح استخدمها هذا انا اتوقع العراقي
يكون اخضر مهمه مثل هكذا طبعا استخدام
التكنولوجي استخدام التكنولوجي بكل شيء
الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه الزراعه الحديثه
التي تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي بكل شيء
خمسه بالمئه فقط نستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
بالوقت الحاضر المشين لم ترتقي الا فقط
بخمسه بالمئه توقعوا سنه 2050 من عندنا
مشين تبدا
تتحدث بيناتها وتقطع الاسس الاساسيه
لحياتنا لمساعده حياتنا سنفعل هذا نحن
العراقيين حتى لو الم الفلوس طارقه انا
تعرفون شنو يعني طارقه اعتقد تعرفوها
وشكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]